bonsoir nouvelle semaine sur téléphiles
pour le 7-8 nous allons faire le tour de
l'actualité locale au cours de la
prochaine heure comme chaque soir en
direct de 18 à 19 heures reportage et un
invité chaque oeil déjà sur ce plateau
catherine boujis bonsoir vous êtes en
attente d'une greffe de moelle osseuse
vous résidez dans les yvelines à bois
d'arcy vous allez nous livrer votre
témoignage comment se passe votre
quotidien alors qu'une semaine de
sensibilisation vient de débuter pour
que tout simplement personne n'hésite à
faire un don le don c'est simple c'est
gratuit en plus
vous allez nous expliquer comment cela
fonctionne dans un instant également sur
ce plateau mathieu colombani bonsoir son
et délégué général du parti
chrétien-démocrate conseiller municipal
à montigny le bretonneux responsable de
la manif pour tous ceux ci à saint
quentin en yvelines vous étiez présent
hier à paris lors de la nouvelle
mobilisation lors de la nouvelle manif
pour tous manifestation qui a connu
quelques débordements christine boutin
la présidente de votre formation
politique demandent d'ailleurs la
démission du ministre de l'intérieur
manuel valls nous ouvrons pour débuter
une page politique dans cette édition du
25 mars christine boutin par ailleurs
conseillère générale des yvelines qui je
le disais à l'instant ne décolère pas l
attente de françois hollande tout
simplement le retrait de ce projet de
loi permettant le mariage pour tous on
va d'ailleurs l'écouté christine boutin
c'était au milieu de cet après midi in
interrogé par catherine relate en effet
pas compte et il est manifeste que nous
étions plus de 300 milles et et tout le
monde est d'accord pour dire qu'il ya la
plus grosse manifestation depuis près de
vingt ans donc lui il doit donner sa
démission
enfin monsieur balle il a été débordé
c'est pas la manifestation qu'il a
débordé c'est lui qui a été débordés
parce que j'avais sous-estimé le nombre
des personnes et nous ont enfermés comme
dans des boîtes de conserve sur deux
la mieux qui fait que effectivement il
ya eu des gens qui bien sûr mais ceci
n'est pas trop grave si le président de
la république comprend que la france
profonde est en train est en état de
l'exaspération et que s'il le faut
faille décision de retirer ce texte en
particulier et de soumettre trois cent
mille manifestants selon les forces de
l'ordre un million quatre selon les
organisateurs pour participer à cette
nouvelle mobilisation contre le mariage
pour tous manifestation qui a débordé
donc l'avenue de la grande-armée
l'avenue foch vers les champs-elysées
qui était interdit à cette manifestation
m colombani
vous étiez présent est ce que comme
christine boutin comme la chef de file
de votre mouvement le parti
chrétien-démocrate vous estimez que
c'est manuel valls qui a été le préfet
de police qui a été qu'ils ont été
débordés ou les organisateurs de cette
manifestation par l'ampleur et donc des
débordements vers les champs elysées que
c'était interdit je le rappelle il y a
une certitude le ministre de l'intérieur
a annoncé vendredi cent mille
participants
ils annoncent aujourd'hui 300 me nous et
nous étions donc trois fois plus que
prévu
il a donc été lui-même dépasser les
forces de l'ordre ont été dépassé à
plusieurs reprises les effectifs des
forces de l'ordre n'étaient pas à la
hauteur de la mobilisation
c'est la troisième grande mobilisation
parisienne nous étions 300 milles en
novembre nous étions 1 million au mois
de janvier nous étions hier un million
quatre le gouvernement ne prend toujours
pas la mesure de ce printemps français
qui s'élevait donc il ne comprendra pas
la tension montera et il est
inacceptable que dans une démocratie qui
aspirent à vivre en paix qu'une ministre
urrugne une ancienne ministre de la
république se fasse gazé et matraqué il
n'a il est inacceptable que des
parlementaires en exercice je pense à
hervé mariton à sébastien oui valérie
rosso debord et d'autres se fasse gaz
est aussi dès que vous parlez en
exercice ne sont pas des casseurs
une ancienne ministre de la république
n'est pas un casseur n'y avait pas de
casseurs un autre manifestation
justement à vous poser tout d'abord les
champs elysées c'était une avenue
interdite pour la mobilisation pour
autant les manifestants s'y sont
retrouvés pourquoi pourquoi les
organisateurs n'ont pas empêché les
manifestants de de s'y rendre
et puis y ait une autre question aussi
par rapport à la logique de la
démocratie que vous évoquez au delà de
ça le projet de loi est déjà passé par
l'assemblée des députés du peuple des
élus se sont prononcés ensuite le sénat
tranchera modifiera avant bras si
nécessaire mais pour l'instant la loi
suit son cours démocratique le peuple
est souverain et délègue sa souveraineté
ou parlement lorsque le peuple estime
que le parlement n'est pas légitime
il a le droit de se réapproprier sa
souveraineté qui lui appartient de droit
tel est le ciel d'intel et les gens de
manuels et lens ont réservé à la version
sur malte - un ferry en france est elle
est l'essence de notre constitution est
tel est le sens de notre mouvement
comme je disais comme christine boutin
le disais à l'instant c'est un mouvement
d'ampleur
la france se réveille il s'agit d'un
printemps français et on n'empêchera pas
à ce mouvement
deux solutions ou bien le gouvernement
prend conscience de cela et là deux
possibilités ou bien et retire le projet
ou bien le soumis au référendum
puisqu'il est si sûr de lui qui le
soumettent au référendum ou bien il ne
comprend pas et ne prend pas la mesure
de l'ampleur de cette manifestation de
ce grand mouvement et dans ces cas-là il
s'expose comme nous l'avons vu hier à
des tensions tout simplement que ça veut
dire de nouveaux débordements
vos nouvelles violentes et quand le
peuple ne se fait pas entendre
il commence à crier voilà vous étiez
parmi les différents manifestants vous
organisez la mobilisation sur saint
quentin en yvelines vous étiez combien à
partir justement de 59 59
nous étions en tout cas sur les villes
de montigny et voisins aux alentours de
2000 et quelles sont les personnes qui
manifestent alors qu'elles se sont
passées sur la manifestation a aussi vu
des parents avec des enfants c'est pour
ça qu'il a effectivement ce sont des
gens qui ne l'ont jamais fait de
politique il ya six mois nous étions
cinq entre montigné voix à montigny nous
étions une quinzaine à voisins il savait
à peine coller des affiches aujourd'hui
tracts y colle des affiches se sont
devenus des militants au sens premier du
terme
ce sont des familles des gens qui ont ce
sens monsieur madame tout le monde
ils ont des familles un métier et fonça
le soir à côté parce que la cause leur
est cher et parce qu'ils pensent que
c'est un projet de six fils de
civilisation qui est derrière
s'il ya une nouvelle mobilisation
déferlera mtv imagine que vous allez
organiser d'autres mobilisations à ce
que vous demandez à ces familles qui
viennent avec leurs enfants de laisser
leurs enfants chez eux ou pas
quand on voit comment évolue la
situation se sera fait au cas par cas
selon les options est ce que c'est une
bonne chose d'aller manifester avec les
enfants notamment et que par définition
nous sommes là pour défendre la famille
et pour défendre les enfants il est
normal que les enfants soient là après
s'il y a des actions un peu plus il y à
une exposition pour les personnes âgées
ou les enfants
effectivement nous appellerons les
enfants et les personnes âgées à rester
chez elle hier des enfants de 7 ans ont
été gazés le rôle des forces de l'ordre
et de gaz et des enfants de 7 ans est-ce
que les masculins avec des en or est ce
qu'un enfant d'un an et à raison j'ai à
l'ordre public je ne crois pas donc ce
gouvernement fière a été a été dépassé
et à user de manière disproportionnée de
la violence
le sénat va examiner la loi à partir du
4 avril nous aurons d'ailleurs
l'occasion d'en parler sur ce plateau
avec gérard larcher l'ancien président
du sénat également maire de rambouillet
il sera sur ce plateau les
à moins de cette loi au sénat d'ici la
nouvelle mobilisation vous attendez
mobilisation tout le temps et partout
nous restons mobilisés
encore une fois je vous rappelle que la
loi sur l'école privée en 84 avait été
adopté je vous rappelle que le cpe avait
été promulguée le peuple est souverain
le peuple français décidera lui-même de
l'avenir de ce texte merci monsieur
colombani qu'était d'ancienneté pour
débuter cette édition du 7 8 et revenir
sur cette manif pour tous nous passons
au titre à présent de ce 25 mars les
autres sujets que nous allons aborder au
cours de la prochaine heure la course
aux municipales lancé pour la droite à
magny les hameaux
chantal jouanno l'ancien ministre des
sports sénatrice udi de paris était
l'invité du collectif manie nouvelle
énergie dont la responsable aurore bergé
militante ump pourrait mener une liste
aux prochaines municipales
la nouvelle miss yvelines est étudiante
en tourisme à guyancourt elle s'appelle
anaïs morel et elle habite rambouillet
la jeune fille de 19 ans a reçu son
titre ce samedi des mains de marine
l'orphelin miss france une nouvelle
maternité qui sera construite d'ici deux
ans au centre hospitalier de versailles
elle permettra d'assurer 2500
accouchements par an indispensable quand
on sait que de nombreuses femmes sont
obligées d'aller accoucher dans des
départements voisins faute de place et
puis du sport en rugby plaisir qui se
qualifie pour les playoff pour la
deuxième année consécutive le match de
la peur pour les locaux ce week end
tournée dorénavant vers les phases
finales ils devront toutefois être un
peu plus constant et pour le point sur
l'actualité sportive rendez vous pour le
7-8 sport ce sera dans une petite demi
heure avec anthony rech
et je le disais aussi un tout à l'heure
avec vous catherine bourgis nous
reviendrons sur le don de moelle osseuse
une semaine de sensibilisation des buts
pour alerter toujours sur cette pénurie
actuelle c'est la huitième semaine de
mobilisation et il faut encore se
mobilisent et je rappelle que vous êtes
en attente justement de deux greffes
on reste pour l'instant si vous le
voulez bien dans ce domaine politique
avec henri guaino pour le député ump de
la 3e circonscription des yvelines qui
sera très certainement
suivi par le juge jean-michel gentil
pour outrage à magistrat apprenant la
mise en examen de nicolas sarkozy pour
abus de faiblesse le député yvelinois
avait estimé vendredi que le juge avait
déshonoré la justice s'est déshonoré les
institutions henri guaino devrait
recevoir prochainement une citation à
comparaître la peine maximale pour ce
délit est de 6 mois de prison et 7500
euros d'amande
c'est dans ce contexte sur le terrain
que la campagne des municipales se
poursuit dans certaines communes
notamment à magny les hameaux
actuellement obtenus par le parti
socialiste cette commune ferait bien les
affaires de l'ump chantal jouanno
l'ancien ministre du gouvernement fillon
s'est rendu dans cette commune ce
week-end samedi matin pour soutenir
celle qui devrait mener la liste
d'opposition lors du scrutin de mars
c'était donc samedi matin dans un
restaurant d'ailleurs à deux pas de
l'hôtel de ville
le collectif nouvelle énergie à magny
les hameaux continue à occuper le
terrain à un peu moins d'un an des
élections municipales sa responsable
roro berger ump a convié samedi matin
chantal jouanno ancienne ministre des
sports du gouvernement fillon
aujourd'hui sénatrice udi de paris pour
une rencontre débat pour nous c'est de
rencontrer lémanique waddell à la
rencontre c'est ce qu'on fait avec une
lettre d'information avec un blog avec
du porte à porte pour aller vers eux et
voir justement quel est le projet qui
sera le plus adapté à ce territoire
donc évidemment le fait de se réunir de
se retrouver lors de ces réunions ça
nous permet aussi de les entendre leurs
préoccupations et de construire
progressivement le projet qui sera porté
par manny nouvelle énergie sport
environnement un programme en
construction au gré des échanges avec la
population et une candidature pas encore
officialisé même si pour celle qui fut
aussi championne de karaté la jeune
conseillère politique de l'ump est déjà
bien rentrés sur le tatami j'aime
beaucoup son combat et son engagement
j'aime bien ses idées parce que ça fait
partie des jeunes pousses enfin c'est
plus une jeune pousse politique
d'ailleurs maintenant qu'ils ont
énormément d'avenir donc
donc c'est pour ça on a besoin toujours
un peu de d'aller soutenir les personnes
en qui on croise est nécessaire ump ait
eu des mains dans la main une
configuration que l'on peut donc
aisément imaginer reconduite lors de la
constitution des listes pour les
municipales probablement avant l'été
déjà on n'est pas encore sur la
constitution des listes on n'est pas
encore sûr le temps d investiture ce qui
est sûr c'est que je suis très investi
sur la commune ce qui est sûr c'est que
le jour on organise vous en serez
informés et en tout cas on s'y prépare
et on se prépare avec ma nouvelle
énergie